this episode is brought to you by
Shopify one of my absolute favorite
companies and they make some of my
favorite products Shopify is the
Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide and
I've known the team since 2008 or 2009
but prior to that I wish I had
personally had Shopify in the early
2000s when I was running my own
e-commerce business I tell that story in
the 4-Hour Work week but the tools then
were absolutely atrocious and I could
only dream of a platform like Shopify in
fact it was you guys my dear readers who
introduced me to Shopify when I pulled
all of you about best e-commerce
platforms around 2009 and they've only
become better and better since whether
you're a garage entrepreneur or getting
ready for your IPO Shopify is the only
tool you need to start run and grow your
business without the struggle Shopify
puts you in control of every sales
Channel doesn't matter if you're selling
satin sheets from shopify's inperson POS
system or offering organic olive oil on
shopify's all-in-one e-commerce platform
however you interact with your customers
you're covered and once you've reached
your audience Shopify has the internet's
best converting checkout to help you
turn browsers into buyers Shopify Powers
10% of all e-commerce in the United
States and Shopify is truly a global
Force as the e-commerce solution behind
Al Birds rothis Brooklyn and and
millions of other entrepreneurs of every
size across more than 170 countries plus
shopify's award-winning help is there to
support your success every step of the
way if you have questions this is Poss
AB ility powered by Shopify so check it
out sign up for a $1 per month trial
period at Shopify that's s h o p i FY
shopify.com Tim go to shopify.com Tim to
take your business to the next level
today one more time all lowercase
shopify.com
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for DEC
Dees tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back onone
putting one leg on top and repeating all
of that ad nauseum but now I am falling
asleep in record time why because I'm
using a device was recommended to me by
friends called the Pod cover by8 sleep
the Pod cover fits on any mattress and
allows you to adjust the temperature of
your sleeping environment providing the
optimal temperature that gets you the
best night's sleep with the Pod covers
Dual Zone temperature control you and
your partner can set your sides of the
bed to as cool as 55 de or as hot as
110° I think generally in my experience
my partners prefer the high side and I
like to sleep very very cool so stop
fighting this helps based on your
Biometrics environment and sleep stages
the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wakeups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its best-in-class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable conquer this
winter season with the best in sleep
Tech and sleep at your perfect
temperature many of my listeners in
colder areas sometimes that's me enjoy
warming up their bed after a freezing
day and if you have a partner great you
can split the zones and you can sleep at
your own ideal temperatures it's easy so
go to 8sleep.com
spelled out 8sleep.com Tim and save $250
on the Pod cover by eights sleep this
winter eight sleep currently ships
within the US Canada the UK select R in
the EU and Australia
optim at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can I ask you a personal
question now see broken
time I'm a cybernetic organism living
dissue over metal
EMP hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferris welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferris show
where it is my job each and every
episode to deconstruct worldclass
performers to tease out the backstories
the Frameworks the philosophies the
tactics and so on that you can apply to
your own lives and my guest today has
been in the works for a long time I'm
thrilled to have him and if I'm not
mistaken this is his first long form
podcast ever G LTE who is the founder of
Cirus solle one Dr foundation and Lun
Rouge I'm anouncing that correctly my
apologies for the French which I do not
speak he was named by Time Magazine as
one of the most influential
personalities in the world and has been
recognized as one of the most creative
and Innovative Minds by K Nast an artist
entrepreneur and philanthropist G is a
three-time winner of the Ernst and Young
entrepreneur of the Year award which
included World entrepreneur of the year
he is a knight of the national order of
Quebec and an inductee of the Canadian
business Hall of Fame he has been
granted the Insignia of the Order of
Canada the highest distinction in the
country and in 2010 received his star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame guy now
dedicates his time to his company Lun
Rouge and his International nonprofit
one drop Foundation which aims to ensure
sustainable access to Safe Water
Sanitation and hygiene for communities
everywhere through Innovative
Partnerships creativity and the power of
art this is a wild conversation full of
a lot of unbelievable stories and we
take a few minutes to warm up but
definitely stick around there's a lot to
learn there are many many negotiation
tactics philosophical tenants and more
that you can pick up from this
conversation you can find him on
Instagram at gber DJ and you can find
his new projects which are brand new
projects and they will contain
descriptions of some different projects
that we allude to at the end of the
conversation and that is frugs f o
gs.com and you can get to the English
with slen so frs.com
and without further Ado please enjoy a
very wide- ranging very tactical very
hilarious conversation with G
laber ke nice to see you thank you for
making the time I know you are a man on
the road you are a man on the move which
I suppose would be on brand as I did
research for this conversation you seem
like a very high hper kinetic man and I
thought we might start in 1977 I might
be getting the date right I might be
getting the date wrong a trip to Europe
what prompted this trip to Europe and
what was your experience to understand
this desire hitting the road and engage
in that Journey which was a very
important moment or year of my life we
have to go back a little bit in my
childhood there's always that famous
question that adult ask to kids what do
you want to do when you're an adult and
my answer back then was well I want to
discover the world and I want to travel
and that came from three very important
key moment in my life the first one was
that was the day of when my father
brought the first colar TV in the house
and the first program we watch was a
National Geographic program that
showcased basically something I've never
seen in my life which was animals that
doesn't exist in my hometown and my
country colors of skin or dressing of
people so I was just like so amazed by
this colorful impact that it have on me
that was like trigger my curiosity and
it stays at that moment it had grow
slowly and obviously I was a big fan of
those National Geographic every time it
was coming it was like yes I want to see
what's more on this planet actually at
that time it made me realize and my mom
explained me and said listen you're not
only living in a city or or a province
or on a country on a continent you're
living on a planet and that made me
realize that the world was bigger than
my backyard second things
1967 which was the world uh Expo in
Montreal my mom another very curious
person that b for the family passport
and almost every day of the summer she
was bringing us to this International
Expo and we visit pretty much probably
minimum of three time each each Pavilion
that was there which again was putting
me closer toward being in touch with the
culture that was seeing in in in the
National Geographic so kind of not where
they were but close to me in a way that
again it reinforced this desire of
discovering what was out there somewhere
I didn't know the notion of distance but
I knew it was far away and the third
things was I think put the cherry on the
Sunday was when Neil Armstrong walked
the moon I was in the summer camp black
and white TV that time bunch of boys
because it was a boys uh camp and we
spent the entire night and it was a long
program because it's they showed up all
the process the expectation was there
and suddenly this guy put a foot on the
moon and it was very interesting because
you could see the reaction of the other
kids and even telling wow I want to be
an astronaut I want to do I want to go
in the moon I want to do what he's doing
and for me my look at that moment was
totally different it was like
whoa The Little Prince story could be
real no it's very interesting and then
it triggered my belief that if I have a
dream or anything that was dreamy could
be achievable so from that moment it was
really okay how could I shape my rest of
my life to be able to travel and
discover that world so obviously I was
about 10 11 at that time and I was still
too young to hit the road by myself soon
my parents were bring us more in North
America and around the age of 14 15 we
did our first interational trip to Cuba
and then this is where I discover Green
Tomato beautiful long legs woman dancing
uh dance that doesn't exist in my place
colorful music Cy dancing so I just like
wow and blue collar the ocean of the the
Sea and the ocean and fish that doesn't
exist in the lake and I was just yes I
knew it here it is the beginning of the
Great Adventure but at that time you
know obviously um I was a minor so I
really start to engage in discovering my
Province H cha king going in the theater
Festival music festival and at the same
time I pick up the accordion of the
family of my father because I come from
a family of musician but traditional
music and I start to realize that maybe
I could activate a little bit this
adventure this adventure using music so
I took the time to prepare a little show
of myself sing songs storytelling music
and then short
after connecting with a couple of other
musician creating a band and that at for
three years perit us to travel around
Canada and a little bit of the states to
encounter other musician to play in the
street playing a music festival so I
realized that Hey listen I could have
fun playing music I discovered through
this journey the beginning of the
pleasure of entertaining people but
mostly I was able to always go further
and further geographically and then
obviously after a couple years 18 years
old was uh coming soon and it was just
like I'm going to Europe and I had
enough money to pay myself Open tickets
for a year and I about 50 bucks in my in
my pocket but an amazing number of
contact that either had met over the
previous three years or people that have
been in Europe say you should go uh in
this bar to play you should meet that
person he's an interesting musician and
went out hit the road and basically uh
spent almost a year in Europe
discovering the pleasure of playing in
the street realizing the impact of
making people smile but mostly I was
achieving my dream and I came back with
more money in my pocket than I left with
you came back with more money than you
traveled there with so I assume and
please correct me if I'm wrong that
means you were busking and entertaining
and earning money in that way what were
the keys to good busking what did you
learn about effective busking first of
all where do you busk because it's not
every corner of the street that you can
make your get your bread and breakfast
money so one of them is really
to rapidly then the in a city where's
the hot spot for people to bus okay and
obviously there's already Busker when
you Ares so you don't invent the wheel
you just observe thing but then you have
to deal with territorial situations so
you have two way of dealing with that
either you provoke and you confront
which normally is not the right way to
do or you engage you engage in the
street neighborhood which is not always
Busker but it's also uh a lot of
different people of all kind very
colorful very very uh Misfit people very
disrupting people but also amazing
personality because a lot of artists out
there musicians so you engage in a
community that belong to this the city
but what I realize is basically there's
two things the busing business in in in
Europe it was the permanent people the
people who live in that City that didn't
move and they were the the one that was
there every day but there was the
traveling people I rapidly recognized
that if you play the game well if you
you're socially engaged and uh and
respectful of certain rules that exist
and you have to learn about them then
you engage in a community that is really
supporting of each other and then you
make friends and then you decide with
the traveler when to do I don't know two
weeks with the violin player or a week
with the belly dancer or the fire
breeder person so through this
experience it's not only encountering a
community that was much bigger in Europe
that it was in Quebec because you know
obviously Quebec we had the climate
factor which is a little difficult to
bus uh at Minor St the corner street of
Montreal so the timeline is pretty
limited and also the population is much
smaller Paris was my base at the
beginning because where I speak French
arrive there and from Paris and then I
start met a lot of people and then you
start to engage okay do I go Ireland do
I go to that festival and I kind of like
organically the Rhythm or the speed of
the wind you know I was like I was
waking up in morning I was like okay
let's go there Ching again depending the
success of aite you could arrive on time
or not so it was this journey of going
from one place to the other one with
people or alone and uh and making
friends and engaging jamming making
money learning this is where I learn all
my fire breeding things the a little bit
of the performance size of a bosker
because there's a music side and there's
a performing side so this is where that
I start to also engage in uh learning
you know I never been a specialist of
things but I always being a very good
generalist time after time I was
practicing things and and basically my
offer to the street was a little wider
at the end after a year so let's talk a
little bit about your mom and dad how
did your
values differ from perhaps your parents
when you got back maybe a different way
of looking at that would be asking what
their hopes for you were and then what
your hopes for yourself were first of
all my parents were amazing characters
to start they were entertaining not
knowing they were entertaining my father
probably a little bit more my mom my
father had this way of triggering
reaction of my mom and it was create a
amazing funny dramatic moment that was
trigger their own story to be shared
with us with the children and my friends
they were entertaining us all the time
my mom come from a very specific type of
family both of them were very poor my
mom work her ass out to be a nurse hit
the road at the age of 18 she had her
stud Baker at 18 hit the road to
California as an adventure with two
other nurse work colag musician piano
player my father come from the other
side he is coming from a neighborhood in
Quebec which is like bunch of kids hling
playing tricks having fun and getting
away with it by just being what some
people would think bad little boys but
they were having fun and actually he was
the another Wheeler Dealer he always
made his way got broke so many time
because he was a gambler but you know he
was the most amazing Entertainer he end
up his career as vice president of a
Alcon company not because he was for
went a school of that but because he was
the best person in the company when
client International client was coming
to Montreal he was organizing all the
party and all the client was going back
signing the contract and whatever in
need he was organizing it so I learned
this things and by the way and this is
pretty special because I not met many
people who qualify in that in all my
life and many years after I grew up or
still now I never heard a bad word about
my father it was always guest now clean
amazing guy my father was always smiling
it was always like humor smiling not
reacting to things where my mom was that
little uh scorpion like she was pigging
pickings it was mama controls and the
dynamic was interesting but I grew up in
this type of family one brother where we
were fire and water together but now
we're best friend because we're both
parents of the pass out last year and
then the grand family my father was
coming from a family of eight seven
sister and him and the grandmother had
the twins so together you know and the
father side family there was about
over 120 people ons and things and every
weekend and one of the house and nobody
had money nobody was the rich one the
richest one was Uncle that had printer
company he was printing a pamphlet and
stuff like tell you a little bit how
rich we were but every weekend somewhere
in one of the house there was always
from Friday night to Sunday night 48
hour party with a kids we were I
remember we just sleeping on on the
floor 10 kids pile on that they were
doing music play cards have fun drinking
getting drunk singing
arguing and all my life I've seen that
family supporting each other in terms of
when one of them was creting up there
was never judgment and you know this is
what I grew up on so my roots is love
support is community spirit it's like
understanding that nobody's perfect so I
learned a lot out of that I didn't
understand it at the beginning you know
because obviously when you go especially
at the teenager moment then it's
starting to be a little confrontation
and there's many story I could tell but
I don't think it's relevant more than
saying in their heart they Tred to
educate you the parents and in terms of
what they believe is a good thing for
you based on their value so at my time
of my childhood being a doctor being a
judge or whatever was the consecration
you know you're an engineer you you get
a good salary you have security
and I was trying all my life to my
teenager moment to try to explain well
listen I have a call I was like I don't
like that and every time I do that I
learn more I have fun doing that I do
more money than that and now then I'm
yeah it build up you know I want to have
long hair no you have to sh that you
have to go to church it was like all
this type of things so I was very
confrontal and actually they helped me
because when they were punish me they
were putting me into my room and this is
where I learn music this is where
practicing my music by rage I was
transforming my rage in in not being
dark that being said I was in a dark
moment from 11 to 14 for other reason
but when my parents was all of that then
I left home at 14 years old it was
enough is enough one amazing moment in
my life one teacher moral science
because you could have the option of a
Catholic you know or moral science
obviously I was rejecting uh the
religion but I was interesting again in
a moral sense and then one day he thr a
text to all the student there the text
was about kale Gibran the prophet yeah I
have a copy at home the page about the
children I said the children are not
your children I was just like it blew my
mind that text was everything I want to
say it to my
parents so I think within a week or two
weeks after I got in conflict with my
parents and left home hit the road
because they wanted me to cut their hair
and there was another things and I took
the page
and I wrote on the piece of paper when
you will understand that meaning of that
text will be able to communicate that's
pretty brutal at 14 years old when you
thr a text like that in the face of your
father and mother and actually it was a
very important moment in my relation the
first like this is where the first time
I stand by my my thing before I was
arguing I was screaming I was like
bitching but this is really what I said
enough is enough we have to make a point
in a relationship because I'm not happy
I'm at the point I'm quit questioning if
you love me or things you know all the
teenager turmoil you know this is a very
being a a teenager this is the most
fragile time in your life if you're not
being aggressed sexually before the a
hands or beat up but if you have a
normal life this is a very fragile
moment so obviously came back my mom was
crying and stuff like that came back
like 10 days after and then I sat down I
said let's make a deal we don't agree a
lot of things but I will continue my
school you pay for my lunch my my cloth
but I want to be having the right of
keeping my hair long and second work to
earn my own money to pay myself what I
want because I'm tired dad of every time
I ask you something you ask me to do
something for it and enough you know
because sometime things could go there
because I'm trying to ask you things to
be able to achieve things but it's
always a negotiation and you try to
bring back in your way of so I clear
that and it worked actually that deal
work pretty good because without
supporting everything I was doing it was
at least a dialogue that took place and
there was some up and down but I
realized and this is where the first
thing I realized is actually at the end
all this courage that I have going and
hitting the road taking risks in my
adventure I always knew somewhere and I
realized that after and it's maybe that
subconscious or
this third or six cents or whatever but
I realized that hey wait a minute I knew
and I know exactly what they were about
they never told me if you cross that
door don't come back first of all you
know and you know many parents screwed
up when they said that to their kids and
second I realized that if I screwed up I
would always be able to come back I
would have a bed food and love and
comfort and this had trigger this
enormous wave of courage and desire to
even engage more they didn't know that
at moment they think I was crazy because
I was doing more than I was doing
previously and then obviously there was
this confrontation about starting to do
business and entertainment because it
was one thing for them to understand
that I was using art or music to live an
experience in our conversation I always
made them believe that I would come back
to school but I was always every year
extending the return to school but when
they
realize when they realized
at that I was shifting and I conscious
made the decision not go to school but
give myself the chance to live out of
entertainment wow that was difficult
with my mom it took the first year of
sigd to realize it and she collapsed and
now I understand my father it took three
more years because it was still some
issue related to I reached him a couple
times for financial help to help to go
through some tough moment and he was
coming back with his old uh moral or
condition and it pissed me off but we
had had a great conversation in a
steakhous moshies in Montreal a good
bowl of wine and with a big dill pickle
and Kos saland and we make peace there
and from that moment I brought them
everywhere in the world with me we
became good friends we had our up and
down but it was an amazing uh connection
you know in the life of a children or
any relationship with parents or not you
know obviously it's not instant but you
always wish that the complete connection
of the circle of this relationship is
done before one of us died and I did
accomplish that with my parents and this
is another beautiful gift of life that I
had I may want to come back to that I
mean I know a lot of people who have not
been able to do that that may be for a
bottle of wine another time but I want
to connect the dots to Cirus but before
we get there if you're open to talking
about it and we can always cut this
afterwards if you want to cut it but you
mentioned that you had a dark period
from 11: to 14 and my main question is
how you got out of that dark period but
would you be willing to say a bit more I
could share I've been sharing uh people
yeah it's part of my life my close
friends know and I have no problem
talking about that and that's actually
relate to a very big problem in the
world that we're living and it's coming
out and keep coming out year after year
which is all about this Catholic Church
controlling schools abusing children and
being excused because they were the
voice of God so at the AG of 10 my
parents sent me to high school in a
college in Montreal which I was uh
boarding school and obviously soon I
realized with my friends that there's a
bunch of priests that want to abuse you
sexually so I resist that I beat that up
but I had a friend who suicide s and I
and so I start to be very very reactive
and it brought me a lot of angriness
because you know what is the feeling
first year resist I've not been raped
but I've been they try it and I got
their trick I resist I fight it back but
there's some other kids there that
didn't have this courage of reacting and
they were my friends and they they got
beat up in the sense of of it killed
their soul and then one suicide your so
obviously and I was incapable of saying
to my parent at that time remember I was
10 years old 11 and knowing my parents
were religious so obviously will I be
punished or I didn't know I was confused
about the information and I guess there
was a taboo things because I see my
parents was very religious I was
confused so I kept that for myself and
among my my friends so I build up this
desire to destroy to the point at a
certain moment even because of another
event later I left two event a little
bit like that and the last one which is
kind of like the addon of that I arrived
to a point where I want to kill the
person and actually I was not feeling
that so that dark moment really was
present I was doing things that was not
necessarily creative that was more
destroying I was doing things that is
not how it was educated it's not what I
was feeling but I was doing it by rage
and this is where it's super important
to understand that what saved me out of
that Darkness this music and this desire
of traveling and actually
activating the action of getting out of
my city and get out of my environment
because that was toxic it was
contaminated by what I had live as
children and I was not able to see the
beauty and I was just seeing the
darkness and going out of this Circle
geographical Circle had permitt me to
slowly eel this things to a point where
certain moment I remember there was a
very very precise moment where I have
the address I knew where this person
that tried to rape me was living and I
kept in My Pocket always the address
because I said if I pass by there I want
revenge and a certain moment I
physically had took the paper rip it off
put in garbage and that was it I was
leaving my future and I boom it but
again This Is How Lucky I Am do you know
how many kids their life will be
destroyed for things like that so again
what that come from is it is it the love
of my parents this understanding what
your that this feeling that the way you
think is not the way you want to be and
overcome that you know how many friends
have not survived that how many people
have been their life have been destroyed
by living something like that so
obviously once I overcome that I become
so engaged in those type of Valu and
defending that that I become very very
strong about not allowing those type of
things in my surrounding combat that
fight that not with my fist but with my
creativity for me making people live an
emotion because they live a moment of
joy and when you're capable of putting
down the walls that do people put in
general around them to protect because
they got hurt before and you bring them
to a point that that they put down those
wall and open their heart for you to
plant a seed it made me realize that
part of my job was not only to be a
merchant of happiness but a soft
medicine the heer of the soul I don't
know how you could do that and then It
reversed totally at the moment I start
to feel this power that to understand
that feed the circle of life it feed you
back and it was like very very powerful
and and was like trying to explain it in
a colorful way but the dynamic is what I
just explained you so it's very
interesting because sometime people tell
story but they don't tell the source of
why you are there and there's many other
things that I've learned my lesson out
but this is a typical example that you
could reverse negative and build it to
even be better so what do you believe in
that of course that person those person
was wrong because this is not right but
on the other side if I didn't live that
moment maybe I would be a different
person and not realize very young in my
life that wait a minute no I would not
be and I would not use that type of
power over other people so it's it's
very interesting we could talk and talk
this is my philosophical uh part of the
brain but those are typical way that I
learn out of everything I engage in G
thank you for sharing that and I'm sorry
that you and your friends experienced
that and as a spectator as a I guess
participant but from the stands someone
who's gone to many circus performances
it's beautiful for me to hear how you
referred metaphorically to the lowering
of those walls those protective
mechanisms because we don't have to
spend much time on this but I was very
badly abused when I was very young 2 to
four and I have very well established
walls but when I've gone to circulate
performances and there are a few places
in life where this is true but it's
where I can forget those stories and
become engaged with awe and wonder in a
way that allows me to Exhale and
experience these things very fully in a
very tangible way so I just wanted to
reflect back my personal
experience and you'll be surprised
because I always said you know to hit
the big seven which is having the
privilege on this planet to be born on
the right side of the planet having the
love of your parents water food not
being beat physically before the age of
10 or sexually abused wo has a question
around I will tell you it's like there's
not many that qualify for the big seven
so this is very important to understand
I believe in the society we're living
it's a lot of creepy and twisted things
that happen to human being and that
human being to to each other so again
Sig I'm so happy to hear your story
because two things my show were about of
course the spectacular of it and things
like that this is like this was the big
pleasure but the the fundamental
satisfaction was coming from two things
really having the impression that each
of my show was helping to Build a Better
World in two ways first in exposing
because all my show was all about
inspired by the culture of the world
either into the music the costume the
team and things like that my artist was
a mosaic of all those beautiful people
around the world that was performing so
for me I believe that I was a promoter
of one world and by then open the mind
of people that there's other people than
you and they could be beautiful too and
they don't have to think like you that
one the second one is really what I just
explained about this wall because I
believe strongly that the Power of Love
overcome the power of Aid because it's a
feeling so when people feel something
that
extremely profound and deep in the
emotion of Joys well they will try and
they will look into living that again
and again and again and the same effect
when somebody suffers something and this
is why sometime one event of
aggressivity could provoke a monster why
because the emotion is there and he he
want to give Revenge so he's building
even more what he had this so it's like
it goes both way and like I said I'm so
happy to have make that choice of my
life that I could have this tools of
this healing tools that I believe is
think my job at Sig I did a lot of
things but but one of the most important
function I has with when we create a
show my job was to assure that every my
show it could be a fraction of second
that any spectator in the place would
say wow they did that for me you know
whatever it is and if I was able in my
show to make people feel that I did that
for them that was the most wall was
falling down at that moment so again
it's understanding the psychology the
world different way r medical acceptance
a recognition that nothing's perfect so
just like this has all came to my
journey and and sick was the sandbox in
which I was able to build that
castle just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
momentus momentus offers highquality
supplements and products across a broad
spectrum of categories including Sports
Performance sleep cognitive Health
hormone support and more I've been
testing their products for months now
and I have a few that I use constantly
personally I've been using momentus mag
3 and8 eleanine and appenine all of
which have helped me to improve the
onset quality and duration of my sleep
now the momentus Sleep pack conveniently
delivers single servings of all three of
these ingredients momentus also partners
with some of the best Minds in human
performance to bring worldclass products
to Market including a few you will
recognize from this podcast like Dr
Andrew huberman and Dr Kelly stared
their products contain high quality
ingredients that are thirdparty tested
which in this case means informed Sport
and or NSF certified so you can trust
that what is on the label is in the
bottle and nothing else so check it out
visit Liv mous.com Tim and use code Tim
at checkout for 20% off that's live
momentus l i v m o m n t s.com Tim and
code Tim for 20%
off let's track your path to the sandbox
because there are many people who busk I
actually did a very small amount of
busking in Paris actually well but it
pissed everybody off cuz I wasn't asking
for money I just did Acro yoga with
another woman who was there I think
we're actually near I'm not going to
pronounce it properly but near the
gardens what is it or
something I was close I was close we
were in front of the Lou in front of the
very exactly and there are many buskers
many people bu but very few people who
create something like Cirus solle so you
come back from Europe could you describe
some of the key decisions or moments
leading up to Cirus solle after you
return actually when I came back I was
not yet decided if I was going back to
school or not again I find another way
to extend my year not going to school to
tell my father well I need to make money
now could you help me to have a job you
had a friend who had a factory to do a
window for the uh art vs and trailers so
I worked there for months obviously this
was a factory job but it was bringing a
little money while I was playing in bars
with music and still willing dealing
anything that could sells on the side
what kind of stuff would you be selling
on the side not baseball cards anything
not anything anything I will find uh
anything I was able to see opportunity
to make a buck on anything so you just
like buy a bicycle at a yard sale and
then sell it to somebody else something
like that or yeah yeah yeah or buy a old
sale a bunch of jeans and going things
and making five bucks over the jeans at
school whatever I was a Wheeler Dealer I
was a hustler also you know I was good
at BAM I was like a pool and stuff a
little bit of everything you know I
always i' like to put to challenge I
love competition I said same competition
amongst people I think this permit you
to it's like playing poker you discover
personality of people by being a good
chess players that's nice and actually
something I apply in business later on
but but at that moment we're talking
about when I come back to to Europe so
uh
1978 79 got that job and then there's
another friend my from father had
because at that time the biggest job you
could have was to go work on the dam and
the north the electrical Dam the wages
there was like you were sent there you
had the highest wages extra hours you
were working seven hours was like you
were doing so much money so my father
got me that job so I go there then three
days after arrive there my Syndicate go
strike your Syndicate is like the union
of the workers the union yeah yeah the
union got a strike three days after I
got oh here we go my summer is screwed
my money is out bad timing then I come
back they want me to go picking have
nothing to do with their things you know
to be honest I was it's a community that
I didn't even engage with and I was like
a I didn't know I didn't feel
emotionally engaged to piic thing
because they were giving you a check
small check but they were giving you a
check so what I decide to do I said
where did I then go in my Province and
there was one place Bay St Paul okay
which is this little Village North
Quebec which had the reputation of one
of the coolest youth H there and I said
wait a minute I have a little check I'll
go there I'll offer my service to help
against a bed than food that was it and
I'll wait I didn't know when the stride
would stop or not but it end up to be
all summer so when I arrived there
climbed the hill and funny enough I see
j s that is one of the most important
person in my life with Sig and another
guy Danielle G that was my school friend
which was we left for relationship not
on a good note and then I go said okay
why do I end out with this guy that I
want to
see but is part of this it was a
nonprofit organization and I ared at the
time where they were shaping the use
ofel so we prepared the things I got the
job of animating so I was in charge of
the party you charge of parties at the
hostel exactly okay parties organizing
things that's what I was good to I
always been good at doing those things
organizing trips and stuff like to
Louisiana at 15 years old running the
Marty grow have many of those mini story
there that we could talk for a long time
but this one was an important one
because first the deal was they were
telling me we cannot pay you but we
could offer you a roof and a bed I said
that's okay with me but could I have uh
maybe the opportunity of making a little
more money I said Ian your party but I
want to be able to pick up every beer
bottle on the site and earn the money of
the beer bottle oh like the Redemption
like you get the exactly the two cents
or the five cents but I'm telling you
after every day there was a truck on an
empty bundle I made so much money going
back and selling everything those bottle
that I end up having a very with little
contract of music and the bar and the
cafe I end up having a pretty decent
thing and this is where Jill
which was coming out of was also a very
interesting Misfit creature he was just
coming back from uh an experience at
bread and puppet in the verman I don't
know if you remember you know I just
heard about bread and puppet or bread
and puppets for the first time from some
of my family who live in Vermont
literally last week they just told me
about it yeah because you're probably
too young to remember that they're still
there but at that time there was this
leader and the bread and puppet movement
was anti-war right it came during the
the Vietnam War and and they had that
Farm in Vermont that they shape in and
they had a magic wood and every year
they were doing this festival and they
were the master of still walking and
Jill came back of that and said I have
an ID let's do you know I'm doing music
we're doing a little theater said let's
start a theater troop on
stilts that's the end of
79 then in the Falls I got called for
the strike stale and I go back to work
on the dam and Jill in the meantime
choose another partner I said okay well
you're not doing a collective you want
to do business fine I said but I won't
hire you I said well listen I'm going in
Mexico came back went to the dam a month
after Jill said I have the grant of the
thing that you want to be an artist in
my true I said I don't know so a grant
this is from the government the
government yeah yeah basically they have
those grant that you could have enough
money to pay salary for the summer you
know in that region of Quebec it was
very simple 80% of population was
working on Grand salary during the
summer and get the unemployment check
during the winter this is what that
region is about so basically you need 20
weeks to work to get your check the rest
of the year and that's what the life and
most of people was leing on that pattern
but I didn't know so what I said I said
to my employer I said listen I didn't
have a house I said my house just went
in fire could I have couple weeks to
just go organize the thing I didn't want
to lose my
job because if I say I quit that's it
I'm done so I didn't know if I work so I
M that story I got the permission went
there never went back but at least I had
that back off it's always you know
you're playing chess in life I it's like
you make a move but you want to know
what's your back move that was one of
them so So
eventually I accept to be one of the
artists in this theater Tron Stills
which was in partnership with this guy s
we end up to be so bad for the business
so at the end of the season
actually we had an amazing experience it
was a summer of my first big love in my
life and an amazing theatrical original
experience but bad relationship with the
management especially that guy so
everybody was like we don't like the guy
they end up bankrupt at the end of the
season Jill said well you know it's like
I make it mistakes and we all decide to
create a nonprofit organization buy back
the the assets and started under a new
company which was the original the
foundation company that we built Sig
with in the future so step two of that
was to manage and then I was tour
manager I was like uh assuming a
marketing business function I was I was
able to give my skill and uh we had an
amazing uh 1980 Summer this is the year
also of the federal election I was a
candidate at the rhinosaurus party you
know there was this like crazy party I
promising anything things I was a
political candidate we have a lot of fun
quick question so was the performance at
that time still mostly theater on stilts
or had it changed theater on stilts
music fire breeding but that moment I
really had master I was in in all the
skill I had probably fire was the
highest level I was mastering so I had
my pyro license I was one of the best
fire breeder in the world I was de in
device to manipulate fire I was
organizing show at fire and this was my
personal uh I would said the feature and
I was very proud about it and I was
recognized for being one of the best
Quebec uh fir player firem that being
said then we did one season and and the
winter I was always again 20 weeks of
work and people were going and getting
their paycheck for the rest of the
winter it was not my style for me it was
about okay the jobs finished I was
hitting the road all the time South one
time on a motorcycle going to Montreal
key W then uh San Diego and then jumping
there but in
1979 198 and 1979 at the end of the
first year which was my love affair I
discovered Hawaii summer was the love of
my life back then first big love and at
the end of the year it was like the
broken art of my life at that the first
within six months seven month it was
like I went from wow this is love and
second oh heartbreaking is very hard
it's very painful so I had to take care
somewhere so I was a friend that was in
Hawaii on the big island Cora that said
I pass by and arrived there and wow I
was discovering a part of the world that
I didn't see and my I always want to go
Hawaii because my parents told me so
many good things about it and then I was
there and it was very interesting there
was an interesting Heep Community
performer there there was like the EP
side there was a you know nice night
life simple life a mellow things but I
was still in pain and was a very
interesting moment in my life so for the
two first week H it was fun get to know
people but I was I had this sadness
inside of me and I was heartbroken and I
was getting this little cafe or juice I
was not drinking coffee but like this
milkshake type of things you know in the
morning at the same Cafe and there was
always this old EP there I remember he
was a magician I learned that after that
was always the the same thing with me
and the soon he approached me and he
said hey what's wrong with you I said
what's wrong with me you ask me the
question what's wrong with me and I said
well there's nothing wrong he said
you're not on the vibe said what do you
mean you're fighting the read him you
know the guy was throwing me like that
was like sitting down didn't even invite
himself he invited himself he wait a
minute I'm in my bubble of pain and then
just keeps throwing me those thing
you're not feeling the vibe of the the
island and he said certain one said you
know what I know I'm disturbing you
there but I will tell you one last thing
I said try to feel the rhythm of the
island and the island will bring you on
the right side of your soul boom okay
what is that and that momentom and and
you know I I could be very thing but I
listen you have to understand remember
KET things is like my first
philosophical ring and I RAM on it
everything that make poetic sense or
whatever I was that got my attention
after that because when you're capable
of reading behind the word and the
meaning of it I start to discover and
this is where I start to like words
before that it was pain but now I start
to understand thing and I really reflect
on that and uh watching Sunset and then
I start to just and this
island changed my life this is where it
start to get inspired I connect with a
Lua troops I was doing my fire ants I
was playing playing accordion in the
Italian restaurant going and hustling a
b gam and the bar after and you know
meeting and
realizing that actually so many things
at that moment I'll try to mention all
of that first of all at that time there
was1 type of religion or spiritual
faction that was on there on the island
on the island made me realize wait a
minute because at the same time you hear
about all those fight about religion and
that
and you say wait a minute it's like what
is it and then you suddenly see a piece
of land on Earth that people live in
peace with each other in respect wait a
minute oh something then you meet all
those eer with potion with growing herbs
and stuff like that and there's this
healing Spirit on the island do you see
people that a rhythm that doesn't exist
on the North American continent there's
a pace that is more toward the pace of
the the rhythm of the wave of the island
or the wind instead of the Subway Rhythm
and then you meet a bunch
of performer that we hang out on the
beach every day and perform on the naked
beach on the non- naked beach there's
party there F party and then I start to
for the first time in my life got to
what I believe still today the closest
to meditation on my side I'm not a
meditating guy like I never stopped the
amster and the had but when I watch when
I watch sunset this is a very peaceful
thing and this Hawaiian sunset this is
where I start to think about project
remember every winter I was coming out
of that that was a second year of the
not first year and then second I went
there three years before we did the Fate
for which I'll talk but the sun was my
inspiration moment so I start to think
about project creating this so my
creative mind explode there okay the
reason what the name s Sig is for two
reason the inspiration of the son of the
big Island okay Sunset which are amazing
and at that time in the symbolic book of
symbol sun was the symbol of the energy
of Youth so that was this is the name of
my company so de it came later but
before that while I was there every
witer was going that finding my old
friends and just having it became my
eing Island that for the rest of my life
every time I have a business decision an
emotional distress a question about my
decision to be made this is where i'
find my answers every time I was coming
there I was planting the seeds of my
question and then I knew that when I
come out of there the answer would be
there whatever decision I made and it
were pretty much all good so this is
where the evolution of the theater troop
on stills you know we were trying to
grow and then Jill say okay we'll do a
winter version on skite and on the arena
and not for me there I'm not spending a
winter here I'm a beach bomber I'm not a
skew bomber and this is where I start to
talk about the project of a street
performing Festival in B St Paul and
with Jill what we did in 1982 we went
into this Village which is very
traditional painting you know this place
is recognized by all this is a Prefer
Place for artist that paint landscape
and things like that so we were already
Black Sheep there the you soel people in
this Village of wolf mentality you know
you have to understand this is all the
old traditional families that are direct
from the founders of Quebec you know the
people got throw in the boat by the
franchise Bing and build this country
and actually it's very love this wolf
mentality because it's all very strong
established family so when you're a
stranger coming there oh I see they're
just aggressive when you say wolf
mentality well yes yes and Clan Clan
they're very protective and you arrive a
bunch of uh people who walk on a UT sale
or maybe dancing nak it around a fire uh
uh taking substance and uh and actually
the first business that's been opened by
our community there it's called the the
muton wall the cafe the restaurant was
called the black sheep
we we made a statement that we will
assume the perception that we have so
you could imagine and they had that
festival at that time which is a art
festival painting very uh touchy White
Glove White Glove Festival you know it's
like an institution and we arrive
wanting to close the street and do a
street performing Festival so we have to
go through all the political level
convin since the and then sponsorship
we're selling you know in our program
$75 little business card size in our
program to the merchant but we have to
convince the people to give us a chance
and it become a success you know it's
like financially we lost a little money
but we had the attention of the big city
in terms of culture we brought the
merchant was super happy so the black
sheep go pitching this crazy idea in
this let's just call it maybe
conservative Town protective Town what
was the key to the pitch I don't know
you know it's like I guess again it's a
conviction like I said me and Jill is a
Charming human being always paus never
raising I'm the I was the jester the the
the jester the jester the Speedy
Gonzalez guy I'm always like hands up
talking like that but with a lot of
passion but we arrived with something I
believe was safe enough colorful enough
business-wise maybe maybe it will have a
good economic impact for us so we got a
shut we got a shut and actually pretty
well on obviously and again the last day
the last day of the last show in the
arena because all those s from home were
there there was Workshop people were
learning how to do clowning in the wood
in the mountain whatever we organized a
very nice program you know it was not a
big budget but people showed up and
mostly a lot of my International friends
decide to come and visit us because we
were booking co- booking the big
paycheck was from the main Festival in
Quebec City but I got the good deal if I
was getting a deal for them Quebec so
that justified them to come and I got
them for a good price but we had that
closing show in the arena which was
everybody on the scene together and
where the last moment is the ffar is
there and I'm blowing fire and that
moment is a
thunderstorm and we're playing that
track that's called the ful which mean
the person that walk on the on the wire
is became more ANM tracks and we're in a
grand finally and suddenly the storm
shut down all the electricity and we're
just with the the flame the cam super
dramatic and I say gooseb and this there
was a big big quantity of of the Quebec
Street performer and this is where we
look at each other it was so emotional
and I said okay let's think about maybe
it would be time to think about creating
our own
circus okay and this is what inspired me
the first flame of inspiration came wow
look at all us together on stage imagine
under a Biga start to share that but
obviously starting a Cirus far more
difficult than doing a street performing
Festival so we did a second year 198
that was 1982 in 1983 we do the the
second version of it and that's greater
success and then we got the attention of
the government because 1984 was a
celebration the 450th anniversary of
discovery of Canada both celebrating by
the federal side and the provincial side
and you have to understand the
provincial we're French Canadian we're
frogs or french fries and then the an
accent on the other side and obviously
the government want to celebrate and and
both take a position very political so
so there's a lot of money that is thrown
for cultural shows activities or things
so special money so I've been invited
based on the success of f to depose a
propose a project and this is where at
that moment said well this is our window
so we build relationship with the
director of programming but we're still
in remember I'm dealing now with the
government a cultural Minister that is
so in the highend class C I'm hanging
out with the Stars so you're thinking
about a government where this minister
of culture is totally star system thing
you know in all the different department
of culture you have dance opera singing
Whatever music street performing circus
was not there basically you have to
understand the social reality there's
and the mentality of whatever Festival
government was about pay them a sandwich
they'll Entertain You for 50 minutes
okay so so this is where we started
their assumption was it was very low we
the low brain you was down this food
chain okay we're way down the food chain
everybody get the money everybody get
the contract and thing and here I am
with one other friend that wasel LE
which actually is the real co-founder is
not the other one the other one came
later but there's one real co-founder
that left after the first year so we
engage ourself of going pitching to the
government and then there's different
level of contract you could get but
there was this artistic director that
was in Char of
programming that really we had connect
but I was pushing him to the he was
coming red sometimes this not what I'm
asking you you know we we had to fit in
the in the formula and I'm trying to P
the first Quebec circus and I'm trying
to explain you believe in him they said
you will not be able to sell that to the
government you will not I said no no no
this is this is the time and then slowly
VI slowly they oblig us to hire or put
in our team somebody that was recognized
by government a friend of mine we play
with her but she was absolutely not the
same level but slowly and I will always
remember at ding because there was that
famous cap of a million dollar contract
and it's not Grant those were contract
negotiating and my project that what I
want to do with some compromise was
costing 1.7 million but to have over a
million dollar you have to the uh
Minister Council so they didn't want to
bring a freak like me as a proposed
content provider especially not that
Minister that doesn't like Street
reformer so basically I will always
remember you pitch in front of
commissary the minister and Stu I have
two document on table one big cover
collars and I put a corner there and I
have a black and white one okay and then
because they asked me to stay at
$999.99 okay $1 under the million doll
project and I didn't work so I presented
black and white everything of my project
I present black and white I said this is
a project and there's one of course I've
seen the document I said what is this
other document with color I said well
it's not important it's like this is the
1.7 you don't want
it and I res I'm playing the game full
on the game no no no you're just like
this what you get for a million and
eventually somebody had ask me convinced
me and it was part of the game actually
this all negotiation colorful
negotiation I call that strategic
thinking understanding human nature okay
and it's very interesting and I learn
all that in the street you know because
in the street is basically you have a
fraction of seconds to decide if you hit
and run if you hit or run fast or talk
but you don't have one minute to
converse if there's a situation there so
one of the biggest skill in business I
Learned was in the street because of
this dangerous environment or you make
friends or you run or you're ready to
face a more physical reality so
obviously there was a compromise there
where it was we cannot give you $1.7
million now but let's start with 1
million and we promise you that over the
summer we'll be able by Exception by
Exception by exception to get to your
budget so basically I had my $1.7
million contract and with all the hard
start we were the star of the summer you
know everybody was failing huge failure
we fell too in the first month but the
beauty of it is we were the product that
was going in the country so you know the
in the countryside so the first month
was a disaster we lost our big top it
was raining and was like it was like
conflicts the artist was fighting and
like there was a whatever happened at
the beginning we were in the mud up to
the throat but one month after our show
was so tight you were able to prototype
it in the countryside you're able to be
a mess but it didn't matter because you
could refine it yeah because they asked
us the minister want to keep the big
city and the stars of big city they put
us on the third row you know go go in
the in the cheap country yeah yeah where
were the piece of bread that was thrown
in the country to
satisfy to touch everybody with a
celebration thing but at the end it
became the best thing that ared for us
because when we arve in the big city
because we did play in Big City we arve
so ready we became the success of the
summer presswise public-wise and
government wise and prime minister was
and he said why a minute those are the
type of because you have to understand
we're right in the middle of the
independent movement and the prime
minister at that time was trying to
always say we're not done for a little
bread coming out from the religious
things by and then and we lost
everything to the English rest of Canada
in terms of the economy so this Minister
was like believe in the French Canadian
creativity business skill and stuff like
so we became the symbol yeah totally and
I devel loveed that relationship that
Prim Prim Minister and he fell in love
with that we were his case or the
product and the example of what he meant
so basically the second year he like
twist the arm of the minister of culture
he said no you if you want that amount
you have to give them so it was a very
important thing so so obviously year
second was more being in the by yourself
in the business but this is the
beginning of s this is how it came and
that's how it take place so let me pause
for one second so in that meeting you
have the black and white copy you have
the color copy so you're playing human
nature and you're doing it really well
because of in part your experience
learning lessons on the street still
when you walked in I assume that their
perspective was that street
performing again lowest on the food
chain right so what else was there in
the presentation that made them change
their mind over time because that was a
year in preparation for meetings uh we
stly
got Ally all right you developed some
relationship Financial Officer which is
a big man M mat became a Defender then
the Press person was in love with you
know it's like there was so many the
shako director of creation that was like
pushing he want our project so suddenly
the administration the people at the
administration level not at the decision
level while middle level decision level
start to recommend us I said no you have
to have that type of programming and all
this this is the they became or Defender
and actually and we had certain alive
but slowly we convinced them by I
believe what they believe was a great
creative project but also were
enthusiasts we were a bunch of kids you
have to understand we were coming from
the streets and this was a window and as
a Wheeler Dealer V this is an
opportunity I'm not giving like unless
the fish is cutting the line I'm taking
that fish out of the pound okay
so I was really always in this like War
I was on a mission and I achiev it and
because what I was carrying on my
shoulder is the dream of all the
community in Montreal or Quebec that for
years was talking about the dream of
doing a circus but never nobody
organized it and I had the credibility
of that tribes because I did the street
performing Festival so I was able to AE
behind me the entire community and I was
the I was giving kind of like the C
blown to make it happen and without
having to go through this Collective
process of thing because you know I
believe in consultation I believe in
collectivity but a certain moment I
believe also that everybody in an
organization have specific
responsibility and mine was to make
final decision and I got to respect of
that it was not I had to gain it in the
first month because there was a lot of
challenge related to that but at the end
I got the support of the community and
the Press favorable critics and the love
of the public so once you have the
Street things in front of whoever you
have an army yeah you have an army and
let's talk about maybe influences
philosophies I read and maybe this came
later so we could also pause this for
later but that your marketing
Inspirations were PT Barnum and Walt
Disney PT Barnum obviously people who
know and read well very complex
character but he basically invent modern
marketing talk good talk bad but talk
about it was his line and you know this
is a guy that was bringing a circus in
New York and will make sure that the
biggest truck that Carri the biggest
elephant will have a breakthrough in
Middle Time Square he will have a
breakdown and and we we'll have the
front page of the New York Times the day
after that worth $100,000 okay he was a
master of that and for people that I
understand even if people thinks that he
was abusing Freaks and stuff like that E
I decide yes to do business with all the
misfit but he gave them a roof in a in a
community so that and the other one is
Walt Disney Walt Disney oh my God and I
it's like this I don't know we don't
we're not on the visual here but over a
napkin it designed the entire vision of
Walt Disney with the things and like
this a famous napkin drawing that he did
yeah the uh like the parks the
merchandising exactly exactly exactly so
this guy was so creative and so business
it was a perfect balance of the two side
of brain of person so obviously this was
my other influence at the time that you
get the million dollars with additional
like maybe it adds up over time to
whatever it was 1.5 million from the
government then you do another year at
that point what was your aspiration well
the other year was almost killing the
other year we were technically in
bankruptcy okay what you don't know in
bwin say once you have those contract
well then you have to go and find a bank
mhm it's one thing to convers the
government but I'm telling you it's much
more difficult to convince Bank M to
help you with your your financing yeah
yeah yeah because the the government was
signing your letter contract but the
payment process of uh government is a
little longer than just signing a check
every month so we have to go and finance
and find a the bridge which was banker
and my God this was like hilarious I
don't know I think we did the Avery Bank
within 100 miles around the city we were
in and basically we're Entertainer they
all a smile but they all told us no with
a smile saying well I like your project
but US Bank we need collateral and
actually we don't know what we'll do
with with a trapeze or a tent or a a
crane truck or a a counter of hodg if
you fail and D listen this is a contract
yeah but so but we end up and it's very
very funny we end up in the the last
financial institution we ever thought we
could know not that was a little uh bank
that was was mainly known to finance
strikes so basically you know Union that
have a lot of money and things when
government people go strikes they need a
bank that will manage the strike budget
how does the bank get repaid if they're
funding a strike they take some portion
of the settlement no no no basically the
union have a lot of money but they use
those Bank this is where they put their
money in so this is the number one Bank
in Quebec where the union put their
money their money deposits so most of
their members are union workers right
there's not a business person in
business with them they're all Union
this is a union bank I get it yeah that
have no clue of financing a business
whatever and this is where we and this
is the one bank that give us our first
bank account with uh a first credit line
or Advance the money that the government
they try because that's what they get
they're used to that they use that Union
would say okay okay found give money to
those people we found it we guarantee
the money so it's in their DNA to
advance money to people who have no
money because they have people big bank
account that say we'll pay government is
the same thing as a union they have big
bank account anyway so so so in in this
moment this we established the first is
was not risky because it was all pretty
much guaranteed and we end up with
50,000 profit out of the 1.7 million
couple of equipment but a lot of
experience but obviously it also tell me
that we cannot work under the model we
did that because it was a compromise so
we had to go to the market and then we
were by ourself there was no more Grant
or no more contract from the government
but we had the Prime Minister out there
that really loved that and 1985 was the
international year of the youth for
young people youth so right that that
just Nam me for the one thing like that
for me to build all the next second year
of s under the youth banners and here
here we go we build s and
actually even there I recognize that we
cannot survive with the ambition we had
want I build only in our Province we
were condemned to export on time I see
just for financial reasons you would
have to export yeah there not enough
market yeah not not enough market you
know the analyze we had on the things
was okay we could do three months four
months but to run a circus you have to
do nine months 10 months over the year
and because of the climate and the
population ratio we have to export so
our first line of exportation was
Ontario
Toronto and Niagara
Falls two million visitor Whatever by
month or things like that that's what
the government told us you should there
is like the biggest tourist destination
not here of fall so the way we had no
money from our marketing you have to
understand that we were tied we had a
little subsid have things but money was
always coming at the end and at the end
what make the success of entertainment
is your marketing campaign but we we
were always short on money for for
promotion so we were betting always on
the first night or creating a PD baram
event in the downtown City or whatever
to get a little press and that year it
was going well you know Toronto was
going well but we were so fragile in
terms of a general budget that one city
you know we could afford a little hiccup
but a drastic failure would create a
drastic financial situation so we arrive
that's almost the last city of the tour
we're in ner Falls we all prep you know
for the opening night there's fully
people there all the politician the
local people and then
normally the history tell us that the
day after the sales tickets increase and
we we get our end result second day 10
tickets [__] uh oh uh oh uh oh second
show 65 people in the room when I have
75 worker
okay second day 20 tickets so I went on
I like what's wrong what happened and
then I have a Revolt of the artist we're
not going to play in front of 15 people
this is where the ruled of we will never
perform we made a deal with the artist
said we will never perform is the number
of public is under the number of
artists that was a moment we made a deal
like that but it was catastrophic so
then it's like what's going on and we
did all kind of thing by page of things
we tried to act but nothing was working
and this is where a certain am is like
what's wrong why are we that bad or it
doesn't work to then realize that yes
there's two million people passing in
the airall but the average of stay of
people is 45 minutes and the other one
who stay long they're ony moon or there
are in their room having their honeymoon
moment so we we understand that the
notion of Market study really but the
result of that is we're technically in
bankruptcy and we saw that so this
specific bank and this is a true story
you know obviously we were about $3/4
million in deficit at that time but to
arrive there we had to survive the end
of the tour pay the salary and if we
don't do that that's it so we have a
list of supplier under $5,000 and over
$5,000 we have a payroll to deliver
every two weeks and we have our minimum
Opex C and we cannot Bill back you know
so so you have to pay cash and then we
have no more cash we're coming back in
Montreal we know we'll get a little more
money and we could reduce that and not
overcome everything but we have to
survive that because if we cannot bring
a little more money to balance a little
bit we're done and then who's else we
have no money not sell ticket so the
banker this Union Bank that we have like
I don't know 100,000 that year or
$200,000 credit line start to allow
without approval of this committee first
it was every check we're doing we went
over maybe another 100,000 then he said
wait a minute you know you're go you're
over your line yeah and you know instead
of telling you you can't do anymore he
said please could you don't do check
over
$10,000 I said like wait wait a minute
this is the banker here so we do check
under 10,000 and then second call is
please could you not do check over 5,000
it went down to
$500 so he was in and the last thing we
got of a win it was I think a 25 or
$30,000 payroll the last payroll of the
season who went to there said listen I
know we way over it's like and the guy
said look at me and he said I'll lose my
head I have no authorization I did
things that I was not arised to do as a
director of the bank I said if this goes
wrong I'm dead so but I said yeah but
please you're definitely dead if you
don't help me to pay the payroll and the
guy released another 25 $30,000 to pay
the payroll and then we end of season
and I'm my partner at that time Danielle
we look at each other
if one and we have maybe $20,000 cash
that we put outside and we said to each
other if one supplier come and post an
action like like a lawsuit yeah claim
well just just claim just going to court
then it will trigger all the thing then
very soon what we did is I took all the
supplier over 10 I said to the bank
first of all I said the bank could I
have five six months you know we're
we're doing another tour we have a
contract they exposed in 86 in Vancouver
we have good traction you know it's like
we're popular but we don't we're totally
technically we're broke so I went on
with my director of administration and
me we went to every supplier and made a
deal didn't pay none of them except
three and then we use the cash we made a
deal postponed check eight months in 12
checks all them they all accept why did
they accept they they loved us okay they
trust us I think they believe in us we
were upfront but we had a deal you know
we had a braid of eight six months
minimum eight months of each of them was
postpone in check with the promise that
if the cash was coming first we will pay
them faster my God this is Angel flying
and not only one this is like uh 50
Angel assign that and actually there was
about 250 supplier whatever for 500 to
10,000 the biggest one I think was
100,000 and the bank and the bank and
the guy have to go back so are so the
bank I have to ask so this guy is
clearly just Breaking All the Rules it
seems like to give you guys this money
was he I want to know a little bit more
about that I mean was he just pissed off
at his boss and he was going to quit in
six months anyway I know I'm being a bit
of a joker but why would he I mean he's
risking his job I would think doing this
totally totally but I guess yeah you
have to be there at the origin we came
like we were a storm of callor of
happiness and what we're doing we what
people never saw in the Circ things so
we were we were clearly we were inspired
and we were working hard and we were
working on a business plan and we
everybody understand if we break that
things it could be a huge success but we
were just young entrepreneur that was
leaving everything a Young Generation
have to face when you do business and
suddenly every wall of those people that
normally would put a wall in front of
kids at decide and I didn't interview
everybody of it but I would say for the
banker point because he became a great
great friend it was just like I just
believed yeah and I was ready I was
ready to go battle with my bank
committee you know and say we should and
actually this philosophy was Banks
should sometime take risk business risk
and not only protects you know his
principal would do so much money that
the POR of our things should be when we
feel it to take greater risk over and
above what the rules of Bank rules is
and that's what he was defending
actually he was using my case and
actually this bank that we stayed until
I sold s we were super faithful to him
and for him it became the bank that
every young cultural Enterprise or young
things were to go because they made a
model all of that and they had been able
to service there and I was just like
again this was a type of thing and then
86 we went to Vancouver in one year we
pay everybody the bank and stuff like
that it was all done and then ' 87 we
hit La it was a live or die in La
opening night again it worked most died
that night wait did you say you almost
died that night well listen that date
okay you have to understand we're going
to Los Angeles festival art festival
super again institutional Things
director of programming kind came late
he said well we're interested but we
have no money to book you I said like
she I'm going from Quebec to Canada have
to put everything on things and one of
my partner were saying well let's go to
Vermont what the hell Vermont will tell
you everything if we will be successful
or not we have to hit the big city New
York or or Los Angeles and we had an
opportunity there so I made a deal with
the Los Angeles Festival I said okay
I'll go I'll take my own risk but please
could I have the opening night okay of
the festival and please could you just
at least make sure that in your
promotion your generic promotion you put
us and I said thir could you make sure
we have good press the big name of
Hollywood on the opening date but here
we are we're in a Little Tokyo you know
where they put out in a Little Tokyo
yeah it's everybody else is in the Forum
of that all the big institution they TRW
Us in the middle of the worst
neighborhood there is Little Tokyo okay
downtown LA in a site that is the middle
of side which basically is The Middle on
one side you have one street gang and
the other one you have the other street
gang is one of the biggest crime place
things that is like murder all over the
it's just like wait a minute so we end
up having to deal with the neighborhood
there so we have to you know we have to
choice either way security things so we
decide been able to negotiate kind of a
truce between the two gangs saying
listen I'm coming I come from the
streets I put all my street his story
behind I made them laugh uh you know I
did the clown of myself I got the
approval why because I said your wife
your kids I'll give job okay other them
selling drugs or killing people whatever
we
stealing my God to memorable moment okay
and it was a very interesting because
people tell us put the 20 foot no no
like another 420 foot things we'll give
job so everybody job the security
parking cars uh cleaning hushers uh
selling out dog whatever everybody that
was hired from the two gang there and
actually I think for a very long time
that was a the first time they were not
killing each other in the same roof
anyway so there's two event that
happened that made me laugh one is about
that opening day which you see people
arrive the big limo the big Mercedes the
big Rolls-Royce and they give the key to
the the hood yeah this little kid that
usually would break in the window and
the guy was like going Park the place in
the worst place you could park that type
of car so just that thing was just like
wow wow wow wow just that for me was an
interesting mission accomplished some
to be able to make that but the most
freaky moment was the opening was in the
afternoon and it was so what so what and
people arrive and you know Hollywood
they don't arrive on the dot it takes
minutes oh my God as as we were dying
just that like they had people it was
like 100 degree people were sweating and
like and then okay uh it's not complete
and the organiz well wait a minute this
this star is coming he on his way da da
so we decided to send the clowns
to animate the place and you have the
mayor you have like the governor is like
all the big shabang is there and their
on time so they're just sitting down
waiting until you're they're inside and
then my clown go because we have to give
a little animation preow so I said to my
my bunch of clowns okay just go uh don't
do the things of the pre-show but uh you
have enough tricks uh to make them laugh
my one Benny clown one of clown first is
coming he coming with a o a water o oh
water o yeah yeah water o open those and
start to spray everybody in I said I'm
dying I'm there diey I said I will
really die in LA and then suddenly
fraction a second because you could see
people reacting in salt and then you see
the first body talk but there suddenly a
bunch of people all together give it
more they stand up and it's like give me
more water magic moment wow then we did
the show a lot of ways yeah I could have
gone that's what I'm saying I thought it
was going the other side so finally do
the show Standing Ovation and the day
after is like selles so we were sold out
and this is was the beginning of never
looking back again wow we did have bumpy
road and stuff like but from that moment
there's only one year the Year of a
growth crisis in our our growth that we
lost a little money but since then sick
except the bankruptcy year we've been
doing money money never never been on
the isit year that's interesting super
interesting so if if you look at La so
you told a bunch of stories about La
you're headed to Vancouver you do really
well in Vancouver you don't want to
repeat Niagara Falls obviously now
Vancouver is very different from Niagara
Falls but was there any planning or
changes that you made to the preparation
before going to Vancouver that made a
big difference no you have to understand
that we start to build wealth you know
on reputation and we're able to do media
deal so we're starting to be much more
strategic in our communication remember
the first year was very difficult
because we have all the money for the
operation but we're very tight sudden we
start to generate cash and profit so
again it's support a good campaign so
we're able to buy a full page in the New
York Times and you know and hit and
create I would said attention we were
very famous to every opening night at
that time it was an amazing party that
everybody want to be there and then
after that sell was going and and and
the model was clear click click click
click and then we expand to show and
then the Breakthrough of Vegas with
Steve wi it's just like life or the
universe was presenting us opportunity
and we were or he was enough open to see
them and seize them because it goes both
way and I believe this is something
that's very important for people to
understand how we were thinking said
somewhere in this space or this
Dimension there's something for us and
we have to find it but not only we had
find it but it was coming to us and this
is all the notion of the blue ocean
concept versus a red ocean environment
we basically I create a blue ocean by
and so if we were ahead of time we
package we didn't reinvent nothing the
hard form of C was there we just put
collar on something that was very dusty
and apply a theatrical approach versus a
circus show approach and we are in the
and we once we start money we reinvest
for supplying our organic growth and the
same time that we're building
relationship and having access to bank
money so we became great business people
and that always related to when at the
beginning of Si when I tried to convince
Bank put a place in the board where
nobody want to be a board I said well
now I'm condemned to play business and I
still had play business and had a fun
playing business because it was all
always about the game you know I was
like we come from nothing so what was a
ro situation go back nothing I could
believe that that's where I come from
and while I was seeing successful people
failing because they were starting to
nurture to not having tomorrow what they
have today and start to nurture fear and
there was like no could you explain that
a bit more I've seen a lot of successful
Enterprise there's many things that kill
success right the first one I've seen is
about once you have success you get a
lot of reward financially economically
and then you're starting to nurture the
fear of not having tomorrow what you
have today right and then change your
entire way of addressing things so
suddenly you're not the same person you
don't address your business the same way
you don't address your vision and things
because you're not your fear okay so my
say or that is like danger there is but
please evaluate Danger Don't nurture
fear because at the moment you nurture
fear there's a good chance that that you
call your fear and the result of the
fear so that's one thing and I've seen a
lot of entrepreneur shifting their way
of being shifting or transforming what
they are and deny where they come from
so at the end not being thems and having
a business of success changing their
soul their way of doing thing and become
other people which again could affect
the result compy and the other one is
more recognizing or realizing that a
cema you're not the person to bring your
business or your baby to another level
to be able to step out when you realize
that you maximize for different reason
your contribution to the success of your
Enterprise so let's talk about the first
part of that just a little bit longer
because I lived in Silicon Valley for 17
years and have a lot of friends from
that period of my life many of them have
shifted I would say into trying to
defend what they have or have
experienced more fear here because they
don't know who to trust Etc I mean there
are many stories about trust is a big
factor also so what else would you say
to those people there people you care
about you see them maybe changing or
feeding the fear what else would you say
to them you mentioned something about
trust there's a tin line between wasting
time of doubting versus trying to see
the best side of a person and work
toward making a merge of a person that's
best site and this is a conversation I
still have what with my kidss with my ex
and the actual business is this notion
of to which level you trust without
compromising the fundamental and this is
very difficult to conclude because I've
lived the two
spectrum of that life I got some of the
best reward by trusting people and
focusing on their beautiful soul verses
their dark side and that has been very
rewarding that had provoked the
observation that people have sometime
when you have give them trust they will
fell in the Trap of failing in the greed
ego and power side of life versus the
love respect and Trust side of life
which is what we had build or things
with and that brought me a lot of
deception to people I really trust that
I believe that we had enough experience
together and they fell on that part and
again it happened in my own little Leos
but look what's going in the world you
know driven by this tension between the
two side of it and obviously the people
are driven by greed ego and power every
morning they wake up and then thinking
about how they could be better us you
know on the side of the love peace and
love and stuff like that we get it on
the face ah we look at the sun we
meditate and and we're a little more
slow to react at that so I guess we have
to be a little more organized if I'm
understanding you correctly I mean it
sounds like you're suggesting maybe
defaulting to trusting people and
expecting sometimes you're going to get
punched in the face but that's just the
tax you pay for being optimistic or are
there other ways that you protect the
fundamentals no I would say at the end
there's more success than failure but
the failure are more touching than the
win of trust because it's usually
attached to deception so I'm talking
more about the the deception you know
you're in business you win you lose you
make good decision you do bad decision
that's part of it nobody's perfect and
nobody is perfect in the choice of who
you work with who you trust or not it's
part of doing business it's more deep
than that what I'm saying it's just like
so this is why I guess as much honest
conversation at the beginning to
establish not the contract this is why
in my contract I always not put just the
legal part I always start the first page
by the Assumption the spirit of how a
deal is done because my wish that if
there's conflict before going on the
legal battle you look at what the spirit
of the the deal was and if you have
sensitive people intelligent people they
will relate to this Foundation version
the word of the legal uh things and
that's actually a page in the document
that has the contract it's a page in the
contract it's a page in the contract
where the first page is not about legal
stuff it's about the philosophy the
spirit of why we're doing the dream what
that brought us to that deal what is the
spirit of the deal okay I made the
mistakes to forget that
sometime and this was the most chaotic
things because I'm telling you it's like
if you're not attached to the spirit and
it's just legal we're living in a
country you know not America specific
States hit in me will make me happy
makeing mistakes and not clear it's much
more difficult for a person to
deny the spirit if it's been written
down you will deny say it's not what I
say because when you try to bring the
spirit in a oral conversation they will
always find a way to to justify that
it's not what they say write the thing
it's very difficult for them then it's
betrayal you understand then you know
it's a betrayal it's not a
misunderstanding is that first page I'm
very interested in this is it almost
just like regular text like it's
paragraphs or is it bullets it's
understanding that we desire to conquer
Planet March we will do everything to
you know it's like very poetic sometime
very philosophic it's very Mission
oriented you know we all do document in
business a mission and vision and Stu
why are we not putting those principle
right in the contract when two parties
do things because this become a new
Mission this is built on new value and I
think this is I believe an
antidote against persecution or legal
process yeah that's very smart well I've
not been that smart all the time because
I'm in some case that that forgot to put
it or my family office I forgot to put
it but now I'm telling you this will be
for no on even with experience I did
forget to put it because I guess I even
trust it more that I believe that I
should not put in in it and that became
the biggest betral and business I ever
did so
now it's there
forever see you mentioned a name earlier
that I'd love to hear you say more about
so I think you mentioned Steve win so
how does Steve wi fit into this story
Game Changer Steve WI a game changer for
me when I start see D I always found
myself by going to see as much show as
possible so right up a c I would go
visit the artist and I will always make
a stop in Vegas to see the entertainment
then and then suddenly Mirage arrived
there and the zig and Roy show was there
and it's my the not the entire show the
first 20 minute it was like mindblowing
I said wow I was so inspiring and
impactful for me because
I realize and make me realize that wait
a minute Vegas is as his baby foot of
modern entertainment you know you have
New York on one side London on the other
side but vas is still cheesy they have
big production but still not deep in the
we call the theatrical the artistically
it's very flamboyant it's big thing and
they put a lot of money you have a
volcano you have like showers or
whatever hundred dancers you have the
spectacular but when you Analyze That in
the artistic quality things it's it's
level one and then with this 20 minutes
I say wait a minute I look around it's
one two three four five six Casino they
don't have Big Show or this big show has
been so I suddenly realized and said
wait a minute this
city have the potential of becoming the
third biggest entertainment city in the
world after New York or with New York
and London and this is where C I start
to put a lot of Focus then we have
Caesars was the first one to approach us
from a vice president entertainment part
Caesar's location so we engag in the
development of deal which I had that
that time to put $300,000 they put
$300,000 and we develop a concept of
show it's called Timeless kiss but
Timeless kiss is the first show which is
a but M okay m Island but we went to a
level presented the board enri lock
Terry Lanny and sentur city in Los
Angeles all those very age person with
couple of young executive and we pitched
and we believe at that moment that we
did a great [__] people were confidence
in the show and actually the deal with
them was far away from the deal I made
in the future with cood so I'm back in
Montreal waiting the answer I received a
phone call I was on my treadmill and
this vice president said well sorry I
have a bad news said what said well the
board think that your show is too
esoteric for Las veg Vegas esoteric was
the word to explain me why they not go
ahead with the deal I rageed I don't
think ever in my life I had done so many
hours of stepm in my life in a I was
raging screaming for three hours and
then I was like wait a minute and that
was $300,000 investment at the moment
we're talking
19 90 91 beginning of a success and that
was into the concept development yeah
well yes yes we were trying to make a
deal with one of the casino to put our
product there then that failed so we
went around next one next one is the
Hilton where Elvis presy was there at
that time it was like a a Broadway show
was there same story pitch [__] pit s
oh it's too
complex and then that that one I didn't
rage because I having received that
answer once I was expecting and then
like a week after I received a message
call Steve wind called you you call back
so I call
back it's like he's this very more radio
voice in me said I heard you were
flirting with my competitors have you
made any uh deal with my
competition I said no why I said why did
you come see me I said well you have the
best show in town I didn't even think
you be interested in my brother you have
the best show in town well he said I
would like to have conversation we I
have some things that we could bring S I
said have you seen s yeah I've seen it
in uh in uh Santa Monica in
1987 oh I said we have a new show it's
called experience have you seen no I
want you to see it said where are you
said well I'm Toronto now but I said
before we converse I want you to see
what I am about now okay I don't know at
that moment that he have his eye problem
and vision problem so he said I'll be
there Friday with my CEO and uh one or
two board member so he flow in receive
him look at things and then I see the
guy we go intermission he say I like it
so I would like to bring this show
behind the Mirage and we could set up
there he turned around he said deal look
at the deal and he presented his him I
said well we have to negotiate said this
guy will make sure that you will have a
good deal and I will have a good deal
and we'll make it happen I need to be
activated very fast Shake after make a
deal they bought all the new equipment
build the things behind the
Mirage and uh I didn't know at that time
that for him you have something else he
have the Treasure Island with his mine
and actually want to lock me down he did
that contract just to lock me down so I
can not talk to others because he in two
years after he was building this thing
and it cost his money and on the top of
that opening night my God again all the
big shabang of Vegas and would have very
powerful and influential friends in the
political things they the business side
he have his Bankers there and opening
night one artist animation again but
this one could have been turned very bad
he did that 2,000 times he sliding on
the robe from the tower over the head of
people on the stage we're about to start
a show I'm seeing from the side of my
light the artist fell on the people oh
God I think I
experience what it means and what is the
temperature and the feeling to be in the
Tomb the sound the sound of the bigp the
CEO Bobby bin see the same thing and
Steve would don't see what what what
what's going on what's going on and C
said well there's an artist who
fell on the end and he knew that who
fell I think it was a banker one of the
major Bankers say just F another oh no
and see said what and dead silence so
thank God it was just kind of like hurt
on the shoulder he could have break his
neck basically one inches on the top he
break the neck and that was it for me it
was done terrify okay so we go to show
and you know it was a hard show to start
a show and build up success so the
reaction at the end was good but it was
not the teric you know it was not
overwhelmed it was like everybody was
like is he okay and uh so we overcome
that moment that could have been crucial
and then uh two three months after he
said the real reason what I I want to
lock you down it's because I'm doing
treasure is I want you to do the main
show of this uh thing so the show gave
us and became the Timeless kids that we
me Miss there we Tred to explain him our
creative process which we need you know
you give us a theater we'll design it
for a show but we need dust free and we
need time to rehearsal and with clowns
we need an audience to test things and
stuff like so theorically get everything
First dress rehearsal another magic
moment with Steven my clown the same
Benny by the way the same Benny that is
my clown he want to do a satiric clown
number the fire hose right the water
yeah the same one who done that still
believe is one of the best CL in the
world but you want to do an original
clown act which is about a satiric
number of boxing in Las Vegas and his
game is to set up kind of boxing things
theatrical one invite an audience member
to have a boxing fight that end up to
throw each other Tarts cream Tarts okay
but but the test people are only the
worker of the casino plus all the
executive because Steve went ask all
this top executive go check it out first
we don't even call that a dress real so
we call that a lion then meaning it's
the cage of for lion it's the risk we
taking there and we just want to little
bit normally we invite friends and
family small crowd the room is like
probably 50% of the executive the tire
right there and the number go wrong
Benny Panic the clown panic and he start
to throw all the tart on the
audience so of course I receive a phone
call from Steve when that's doing ski
and as B say what I will not use the
word happen like what are you doing what
is it to throw Tarts to people in the
room in the new theater like they said
Steve it's like this was the lion dance
and we testing it get wrong and stuff
like that the clown Panic will correct
that don't worry that's part of the
process clown panic and I said and he
said there's no F way you can you can
say it on my show that's just because
with all those things there's no [__]
way exactly well I didn't say it you
said
it I just Tred to play with the
situation so he said listen
I'm flying tomorrow I want a private
view of the show okay and there's no way
you will open the show and I will tell
you what's work what doesn't work I have
the experience of that in Las Vegas and
we're there everybody's freaking out so
I'm cranking because it's like we took
months to explain him this process and
now he's like treading me to not open
the show whatever you know the Steve we
wait so we arrive I'm not sitting with
him I'm sitting with Bobby B in a CEO
because he's my friend and that's the
one I made the deal Franco Dron and Jill
s the director and the director of
Creation with Steve and you could see
Steve and you know those show that have
so much mechanic on it you cannot put
the artist on risk so you don't run the
show at real speed you run the show in a
safe way so you mark the step and then
you know it's a process so I'm obliged
to run a show that's supposed to give
him the information what the show is
about but instead of being 100 miles an
hour it's running running at 75 so
obviously you don't see the beauty of
the race car you know it's like it's
like it is just safety safety safety you
mark your Tech a client lining does a
light could affect an acrobat you know
there's all hundred of detail so
obviously everything slowed down so at
the end of the show stand up we have a
meeting with him and he's around the T B
he look at the he talk to him say what
the [__] is this show it says it look
and feel
like a [__] German
Opera fron the director turned around
say thank you Steve this is the biggest
compliment you can ever told me about
the show I
create swear to God this is true story I
see this like
what I just here I just tell you the
show is a piece of crap and you're
telling me thank you by telling you that
by and yeah and Franco explain he like
do you know German Opera is very
important in the word of Opera
institution and and Steve is totally
disabil and then he start to say I like
that I don't like that I I want you to
change that that and then I intervene no
Steve I said I explain you we explain
with the things we're not done yet with
the show this will be a great show trust
me and by the way I have the last word
contractually about what will be the
show or not and his reaction yeah but I
control the room and if I decide nobody
goes in Fair from you then you'll be in
penality because if I deliver a show and
I have the right if you don't want to
let people in it's your problem I would
have done my job and then he turned
rageed because he said you have to
understand Steve wi always at control %
of his narrative everybody's at this
foot here's a little kid from Quebec is
like standing in front of him saying no
when people tell him yes three times in
a row to make sure he understand no yes
and then he turn BBY BN Ste said what
the [__] is that contract I don't have
the last word I said well Steve you
asked me to make a deal with them and
that's what a break de you ask me to
make sure that it will be with us I did
it that was a condition it was a break
deal I signed it to the Creditor still
to the credit of SE at the moment SE
said this is contractually binding Steve
said okay then I will have to trust you
I hope you're right and you will prove
me wrong but here it is I will trust you
see you at opening night just like that
just like that opening night day after
sold out sold out sold out we were the
hit new show Rock Vegas then after that
there was a old show and you know the
story it's like bang bang bang to a
certain point that after he sold to MGM
there's a moment of the pentacle of
things we were responsible of 6% of
about 40 million visitor of primary
reason why people in Vegas and we were
contr almost 39% of every entertainment
tickets in Las Vegas wow so we did
contribute a little bit now Vegas is a
total red ocean but we arrive create a
blue ocean and just like squeeze it with
beautiful show and they were giving us
all the money we want to create the most
amazing show and oh is an example of it
this like Masterpiece it's like that's
the perfect match with somebody who
believe in you have a lot of money and a
team that arrive at creative maturity to
do his Masterpiece so I'll just mention
for people blue ocean the Blue Ocean
strategy also a great book worth reading
that gets more into this concept but
which was a test case story is part of a
case study on it and it's very
interesting and people who will read it
it'll really make you understand how
addressing a red ocean by creating a
blue ocean could totally be a game
changer for an Enterprise and the way of
thinking about your envisioning strategy
yeah total Game Changer and I would love
to ask you more about Steve wi we might
come back to it but I know we're coming
up on two hours so I want to be
respectful of your time but let me ask
you this question which is I would love
to get your perspective on maybe what
people miss about cir Dole and why it
became successful because I imagine
there are many people listening to this
who will wonder and I've wondered this
too why didn't someone else do this well
we were a Pioneer but after the success
like any good success you have impact
creative mind or production company some
will have the easy reaction a lazy
reaction of trying to copy you very bad
for them very bad for the business very
bad for my brand why because they will
play inspir by they will call that a
sick Lon sick of that to try to grab the
flavor and attract them by trying to
sell that they're at the same level
right disaster and this for me it's lazy
people to do that and non-creative
people there's some of that and you have
to deal with that so some dbe I usually
they don't last long but it does affect
your credibility for a period of time
but people are not stupid they will
understand what is the real recipe
versus the fake one right we're the
original then there's the other one that
you inspire okay Young Artists and I had
a lot I was responsible with a lot of
new emerging entertainment company that
inspired himself about what we did and
became the second generation you know
it's like an art you have the first
generation you have the second
generation and you have the the other
one that or we call the derivative
derivative of the bad one you know that
sometime make money out things but they
just copy and they have no contribution
to the evolution of the art but today we
had nurture s had nurture dozen of
second generation of artists and things
and it's not necessarily always about
circus I'm M wolf for example I don't
know if you know M WF so for example M
WF without saying they're second gener
but they are because I know the founder
of some of them and you know obviously
we had a huge impact in inspiring
cultural or artistic entrepreneur to use
us as inspiration and may some of them I
said well listen you've been very
important in inspiring us and many other
there like that and when you see this or
even in Circus as being the little
troops was things are all like babies of
Sig that are defined their own style
that are inspiring and contribute to the
elevation of the art of circus and
that's beautiful and there's more of
that that's failure and actually it's
very rewarding to see that type of
impact you could have on the Next
Generation so yes there people who try
but the clever one are the one who don't
try to copy but try to make their own
signature so G I want to be respectful
of time do you want to keep going for
like 10 15 minutes or yeah yeah yeah
okay I would like to talk about the
community you know which is again the
beautiful 40 years that I live with
amazing colorful people that come from
the same environment of work which is
funny then
obviously I sold Sig
2015 many things happen another story to
tell and I'm jumping to the conclusion
where went from family office different
portfolio explore a lot of things I
don't want to go to details rough moment
Co having to you know I was about to
activate new content new project and Co
kill it all lost my investors and stuff
like you know like starting to lose not
every year now it's like at least couple
of months friends that are dying you
know make me realize that wait a minute
I'm not saying clock is sticking but
let's say time pass fast and that does
have impact and I realized that what
became important from lost my parents
and then suddenly was about wait a
minute one of my dream because I had
some dream in my life but the recent
dream was about hey I would love to go
back with all my group of people or
friends invite them on the island oh you
my whatever and spend couple days or a
night just with a good bot of wine and
just listen what their life was about
just to see the people you love what
they have all because a lot of them I
always kept contact with them but some
I've not seen for 20 years and we're
still in contact we just would love to
hug ourself and and and have a good
conversation again so it changed the
last couple years really especially from
last year about 14 months ago I really
went through this period of whoa what
are my priority first family office type
of money management not my type of I'm
an entrepreneur okay I need action
I don't have the patience of most of the
things one of my investment was the
biggest betrayal of my life I said wait
a minute I want to be with my friend I
want to be my loved one I want to be
with my tribe I want to be with my
family so it shift and made me the
decision that I said I want to do shows
again so the last year about since last
September yeah about a year I've been
gearing up and we developing concept and
and with some of it with my old friends
that we told ourselves let's do
something again and a bunch of young new
kids young people that have the fire the
drive and that I invite to play with us
and make sure with all my elders that we
use this opportunity of creating thing
and transfer the knowledge of what weer
wisdom form them and give them and work
with them so they could carry on a nice
entertainment environment and at the end
what does it mean is what is the
conclusion of that is like you know in
life you could have all the success you
want you could have all that but what is
the most important your family your
friends your tribe the people that live
a life with and the comfort of that is
so much important than anything else
after which at the end if you realize
that and for me this exercise of
starting up a new entertainment company
with new show that I cannot disclose
today but I believe the pretty ass
kicker also there we have first of all
we have a lot of fun we're laughing our
ass out every morning that we're writing
and creating things so we'll live or die
from the public reaction but amongst the
team here we're like cranking up and we
have a lot of Joys but at the end what
all this will permit me is somewhere
hopefully to this new adventure engage
in which I didn't have to is maybe end
up having achieved to one of my goal at
the end which is I mentioned it before
being a good ancestor and this is all
the desire of giving back as much I
could in the time left and I hope
there's another 30 years whatever my
goal is at least under 100 years but I
was fed by so much love so much joy so
much opportunity that what I got was
bigger than what one individual have so
I'm trying to find a way that how could
I give back of all that through what I
know best is creating shows and creating
entertainment companies so this is where
I am we talked about the to one there's
a to two and I'm starting to engage to
three
basically very different and also very
interconnected chapters it would seem
and how much of the getting back to
performing or shows is the performing in
the shows the content versus having a
reason or an excuse to get together with
your old friends and the performers well
there's different Factor on that one is
I I realize I didn't do my
epilog you know I left at play the C I
visit things I had a bad result things
for X reason again another conversation
but what is my epilog in all this
amazing creative production adventure
and what I'm working now is my epilog
the second thing is a challenge it's
funny as much I'm very active some I
have the impression that I could become
very lazy when Comfort is there so I
always perform the best when I'm on the
cliff and it's true it's true and
knowing that if I decide to come back on
that and I'm risking a lot I cannot do
what I did at Su I have to find
different way I have to address every
angle of the artistic experience I'm
about to do with a different look at it
and this is intellectually so so
challenging and interesting so I'm
having a very interesting brain
activities with all those amsters that
keep rolling the amsters are definitely
awake in this brain alive and well
dancing on the cliff well G is there
anything else you'd like to to say any
requests of my audience or anything else
you'd like to add before we close this
first round yeah but if I open my mouth
again it will be $5 by word that I say
from
[Laughter]
noing no problem no problem well well
this has been uh incredibly fun I'm glad
that this finally came together and I I
really appreciate you taking the time
and sharing everything that you've
shared and hopefully we'll get a chance
to do a round to have a good bottle of
wine together have a good bottle of wine
absolutely where are you based I'm based
in Austin Texas oh okay but I travel a
lot so I'm on both coasts I'm
International frequently so I'm sure
there's an opportunity or we can make an
opportunity I spend a lot of time in
Vegas especially by activating certain
things uh we have uh let's make sure we
don't lose contact I would definitely
either a good bottle of s over a good
Japanese meal or a good bottle of wine
the red wine burger and over a good meal
sounds perfect and really appreciate you
taking all the time and to everybody
listening we will link to everything in
the show notes and more at tim. Blog
podcast and as always be a little bit
Kinder than is necessary both to others
and to yourself until next time thanks
for tuning
in hey guys this is Tim again just one
more thing before you take off and that
is five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between 1 and A2 and 2
million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of Tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to tim.
blog Friday type that into your browser
tim.
blog Friday drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one thanks for
listening this episode is brought to you
by eight sleep temperature is one of the
main causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all of that
ad nauseum but now I am falling asleep
in record time why because I'm using a
device was recommended to me by friends
called the Pod cover by 8 sleep the Pod
cover fits on any mattress and allows
you to adjust the temperature of your
sleeping environment providing the
optimal temperature that gets you the
best night's sleep with the Pod cover's
Dual Zone temperature control you and
your partner can set your sides of the
bed to as cool as 55° or as hot as
110° I think generally in my experience
my partners prefer the high side and I
like to sleep very very cool so stop
fighting this helps based on your
Biometrics environment and sleep stages
the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wakeups and increase your
percentage of deeps sleep in addition to
its best-in-class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable conquer this
winter season with the best in sleep
Tech and sleep at your perfect
temperature many of my listeners in
colder areas sometimes that's me enjoy
warming up their bed after a freezing
day and if you have a partner great you
can split the zones and you can sleep at
your own ideal temperatures it's easy so
go to 8sleep.com
spelled out eight sleep .com/srobiyt
[Music]
early 2000s when I was running my own
e-commerce business I tell that story in
the 4-Hour Work week but the tools then
were absolutely atrocious and I could
only dream of a platform like Shopify in
fact it was you guys my dear readers who
introduced me to Shopify when I pulled
all of you about best e-commerce
platforms around 2009 and they've only
become better and better since whether
you're a garage entrepreneur or getting
ready for your IPO Shopify is the only
tool you need to start run and grow your
business without the struggle Shopify
puts you in control of every sales
Channel doesn't matter if you're selling
satin sheets from shopify's inperson POS
system or offering organic olive oil on
shopify's all-in-one e-commerce platform
however you interact with your customers
you're covered and once you've reached
your audience Shopify has the internet's
best converting checkout to help you
turn browsers into buyers Shopify Powers
10% of all e-commerce in the United
States and Shopify is truly a global
Force as the e-commerce solution behind
all birds Roes Brooklyn and and millions
of other entrepreneurs of every size
across more than 170 countries plus
shopify's award-winning help is there to
support your success every step of the
way if you have questions this is
possibility powered by Shopify so check
it out sign up for a $1 per month trial
period at Shopify that's s h o p iy
shopify.com Tim go to shopify.com Tim to
take your business to the next level
today one more time all lowercase
shopify.com
[Applause]
SLP